nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation la croissance des pays
émergents
la stagnation des pays occidentaux et le
ralentissement de ceux en développement
ont rendu la compétition économique
internationale
brut 1 soyons clairs dans la guerre
économique
tous les coups sont permis la stratégie
de conquête de marchés à l'exportation
s'appuie sur une politique offensive de
pillage de fleurons du secteur
stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères clés
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et de
l'encadrement
prasad ce type de pratique il existe sur
la planète
beaucoup d'acteurs chez qui est sans
aucune hésitation ni morale la fin
justifie les moyens